hello and welcome to the shaky science
show where in this video we're going to
have an in-depth analysis of the
different methods of measuring aging and
so this kind of comes under the branch
of a new time I came across called bio
horology which is the science of
measuring the passage of time and living
systems so currently there are different
ways that we can try and measure age and
so in this video we'll look at how you
can do that why you'd want to do that
and what the kind of goal for an aging
clock would actually be and then at the
end we'll look at the accuracy and
utility of these different clocks and
the potential future development of
these clocks and so the references i've
used to this video i've linked down in
the description for further reading if
you're interested so firstly let's talk
about who actually is aging so one way
you can define aging is the progressive
deterioration of an organism over time
however what is becoming apparent is
that this deterioration is a dynamic and
nonlinear process which means that
certain events don't happen all at the
same time or in its same order and this
makes aging really challenging to study
so in terms of defining aging you can
define age by a chronological age and a
biological age so chronological age is
easier to understand and it kind of
simply is the amount of time that has
passed since you were born
but biological age is a bit more
complicated and this is mainly because
it's used in different contexts but one
way of thinking about it is a
time-dependent component of an
organism's Averill health now
determining chronological age is much
easier than determining biological age
so what are the different ways of trying
to estimate someone's biological age
well in previous videos I've talked
about an epigenetic clock and the
proteomic aging clock which we'll talk
about in this video again but in
addition we'll also look at the use of
telomere length as a way of measuring
aging and also gene expression and
elaborate a bit more on biochemical
compounds that you can get from blood
samples but before we describe those
many more detail and assess the
differences and the accuracy in the
utility why do we even care about trying
to measure
age well there are kind of two main
reasons firstly from a scientist
perspective by having these different
measurements you can actually quantify
and defy an aging and try to understand
the aging process better and then
secondly having these estimations can
also be used to evaluate the efficacy of
during protective interventions and so
obviously especially with this latter
one you want to have an agreement on
what method of measuring this biological
age is because otherwise certain
interventions they could bias the
interpretation of the results and so the
idea is we need to get some kind of
general agreement but this is obviously
easier said than done and so what we
really want like the kind of dream for
an aging biomarker so to speak is to
fulfill certain criteria and so firstly
you want to have something that's a
better predictor of lifespan than
chronological age and also it must be
something that it can monitor a basic
process actually underlies the aging
process but this is hard at the moment
because we don't fully understand the
aging process and then thirdly we want
this biomarker test to be something that
can easily be tested repeatedly across
someone's lifespan and then lastly it
also should will it be goods for its
working model organism so it can be
tested before apply to humans and so
getting to these biomarkers really
depends on us being able to understand
this dynamic nonlinear aging process and
so spoken before about the hallmarks of
aging which is probably one of the best
ways so far to be able to understand the
aging process but there's also different
theories of aging so the reductionist
theory is that there could potentially
be a single factor that gives rise all
these distinctive aging phenotypes
currently there isn't any that husband
found however I think this kind of
mindset is somewhat similar to what I
read in Davidson classbook lifespan
where he talks about aging being the lot
of information that is above all these
different hallmarks of aging and then
the second
it's approach is the idea that aging is
just a multitude of simultaneous damage
accumulation processes and so currently
I think this theory of aging is
preferred however what is needed is a
consensus so that everyone is studying
the same aging process and so basically
it comes down to semantics it depends
how you define aging and so we're trying
to find what this aging process is and
we tried to find it by these hallmarks
and so agent could be a common
denominator of these different hallmarks
for the majority of the hallmarks so you
know all of them for example this green
ring may not be correlated with the
aging process whether the alternative
situation is that actually there's even
less overlap between these different
hallmarks and whatever causes the aging
phenotype but what you can do is try and
understand which of these hallmarks are
more important and give them like an age
score and link them further to the
development of aging now this made more
sense in my head than when I tried to
explain it but I hope you so much
understand the idea that I'm trying to
get to you but the idea I was trying to
get to is that the more important the
hallmark is the aging the greater weight
of that score is to the overall age
score anyway let's just move on the last
thing we need to briefly mention before
we look at these different biological
biological clocks is that a lot of them
depends on the training data and how
they were determined in the first place
and then how they can be used to predict
someone's biological age and so in
theory developing these clocks relies on
having healthy disease-free patients
whereby their chronological age should
pretty much be their biological age and
so it goes without saying that each of
these different clocks are going to
depends on how they actually defines a
healthy disease-free patients and also
split depends on the genders used and
the geographical locations of these
patients in the first place so are these
different biological clocks Ann well
firstly there's one clock that could
potentially be developed by looking at
the length
telomeres now telomeres are repetitive
sequences that are found at the ends of
DNA sequences and so as a cell divides
these sequences shorter and and this is
one of the hallmarks of aging telomeres
are protective for a cell so when they
decline in length they put the cell at
risk and so the cell can either undergo
cellular senescence which is one of the
hallmarks of aging as well whereas the
cells stop dividing or if a cell manages
to evade this process it could lead to
cancer development but the bottom line
is is that potentially by looking at the
length of these telomeres you could be
able to estimate someone's age because
it indicates that that cells been around
for longer it's been dividing for longer
and so you've given the caveat that
telomers can also be extended by a
protein called telomerase we're going to
ignore that for now because generally
humans from race is inactive in somatic
cells but even if we just focus on the
somatic cells which are basically any
cell in the body which isn't a
reproductive cell there are still issues
with assessing telomere length as
correlating with biological age and
that's fastly because there's different
ways of trying to measure the length and
based on different studies there's been
different sample sizes different age
distributions and so in multiple studies
show you different correlations between
telomere length and biological age also
they don't take into account Tillamook
damage we talked about this a bit more
in my previous video but effectively
there can be length independent ways of
telomeres also being associated with
cellular senescence and so that could
actually also be masking the signal of
the length and it's correlation to
biological age which is also why
different studies give different results
potentially so what about an epigenetic
clock well I spoke about this before in
a previous video which I recommend you
watch obviously but I'll gave us some
key points again so is epigenetics so
epigenetics is all the non dynamic
information storage in cells so I think
it's easy to understand DNA and DNA
sequence which is the series of
nucleotides AG TNC within the nucleus of
yourself however DNA isn't just DNA in
the nucleus it's actually tightly
wrapped around proteins called histone
proteins which helps to compact the DNA
into the nucleus and the level of
compaction within the nucleus Ferries
so some regions are more compacted than
others and part of this comes down to
the association of marks that can be
added to DNA and to histone proteins and
one of these marks is methylation and
the impacts of adding these marks to
either DNA or to histone proteins is
that they can alter the compaction and
altering the compaction can therefore
potentially cause genetic instability
but also it can lead to changes in gene
expression in particular regions that
become less compacted could results in
an increased expression of
retrotransposons which are normally
silent in the genome and this has been
linked with aging so bottom line most of
these marks are actually quite dynamic
they can be taken away and added and in
particular studies have shown that DNA
methylation marks changed during aging
many of these changes have been found at
so-called
CPG sites and basically what this means
are sites where you see SC next to a G
and it's the seed the cytosine that
actually receives this methylation mark
and then these methyl marks can be
detected and analyzed for their presence
and so a lot of work that's been done on
epigenetic clocks has been done in the
lab of Steve Horvath and in 2013 he had
quite a seminal paper that showed that
353 of these CPG sites had methylation
changes that enabled them to predict
chronological age with a two point nine
year median error and this could also be
done in cells that either had stopped
the fighting or cells that continuously
divide and so if you're interested in
his work you'll find a recent TED talk
that he gave where he actually mentioned
that now they're working on developing
Universal epicenter clock for all
mammals but bottom line by looking and
analyzing these different CPG sites and
for methylation methylation presence you
can try and determine particle age but
there's some key questions associated
with the use of DNA methylation at
o'clock firstly what aspects of aging
does this actually reflects for example
why do certain epigenetic sites show you
such a high correlation with biological
age and other stains secondly there's
been multiple developments of these
methylation clocks and they used
different sites and so these are equally
good so the question is why and maybe
there's some redundancy but the idea is
there's a lot of questions that
hopefully at some point we can
understand anyway moving on the third
way potentially measuring Aging is by
looking at gene expression patterns and
so in terms of understanding why changes
in expression might be associated with
aging kind of gates that it's what we've
been talking about in terms of the
epigenetic clock whereby the alterations
of these marks can result in changes in
gene expression however the technology
at the moment means that this there
isn't been a clock developed so far but
it has potential and so the last clock
cooler cut is the use of biological
compounds that can be detected in plot
and so this includes things like
proteins as I discussed before and a 38
which you should check out because I
think it's some of my finest work but
other compounds found in Bloods include
things like calcium cholesterol glucose
anterior and so there was a paper that
came out in 2016 that developed a clock
that used 42 different features and the
good thing about blood is that it's very
accessible and quite easy to get and
otherwise and so the this clocks been
updated and so there was another
publication that came out in 2018 and so
this clock was slightly less accurate
but it requires the use of much less
taxes and so some of these factors in
addition to the blood chemicals
including such as Texan geographical
location and eesti were actually really
important for determining
the the age which is very interesting so
now we've looked at the different clocks
which one is the best
well there's improvements that can be
made in all of the clocks but if we plot
each of them onto a graph of accuracy
versus utility we can try and get an
idea of where we're currently apt in
determining and predicting biological
age so kind of like the bottom of the
list is telomeres and higher up in terms
of accuracy is DNA methylation which is
kind of the hot clock at the moment but
you know close up is a blood test which
due to their utility also showed great
promise and also the transcriptome has
potential if we can use more deep
learning methods to understand the huge
range of changes that occur within the
gene expression one interesting option
would be to use a range of these
different tests and see them complement
each other however that comes with the
associations of increased cost and
decreased practicality so hopefully this
is giving you good insight into the
different ways we can try and estimate
biological age and as always thanks last
name